Right now, real animals are
being neglected by me.
Hi, I'm Amy Schumer.
And these are
the dozens of animals
I never should
have adopted.
Nobody's fault.
Long story short, I'm now
legally considered a hoarder.
I mean,
what do you expect?
I mean, they're cute as (bleep).
(Bleep).
Like what is this thing?
Like, what are you,
an act one Gremlin?
You are a burden.
That's where you
come in.
Call the number on your
screen right now and just,
just take a few of
these things off my hands.
Like Walter, who only is nice
to you when he needs something.
Nobody walks me, Walt.
This one I call Bait and Switch
'cause he used
to be real cute
and then he got bigger.
Not a Laugher.
Competitive Narcissist.
And let's just say this one,
she doesn't have
a warrior spirit.
Not Supportive.
Mama's Boy.
Spencer's actually cool.
He found my phone.
(whining)
I honestly don't want to have
this conversation
with you right now,
but I will
in front of everybody.
Jew.
Fat,
But Owns It.
And Mrs. Wong is glib.
Time is running out.
My sister just spent her student
loan check on an all-inclusive
trip for the two of us
to go to Turks and Caicos.
The excursions are not
included.
And once I'm on that plane,
the last thing
I want to be worried about
is this dog's water bowl
or this turtle's survival.
Russell!
Get away from your sister.
Russell, you know
you're not allowed near her!
If you call in the
next 10 minutes,
you'll receive this
free T-shirt.
Okay?
10 minutes.
You're so (bleep) cute.
I want more
of you!
But I don't.
♪♪